Coolhaus is an architecturally-themed ice cream sandwich company.
Our sandwiches are made-to-order on our trucks.
We use technology like Twitter, Facebook and Foursquare...
...to get the word out to all our customers and with 13,000 Twitter followers...
...we're able to actually sell a lot of ice cream sandwiches and grow.
We disseminate information to everyone in our staff in LA and also Austin and in New York.
So things like our standard operating procedures...
...to how to tweet out our location is all in this one hub.
Yeah, mobile technology makes sense for us because we are a mobile business...
...and there's not one location that is Coolhaus.
So having a mobile device that contains all of these documents and all these information...
...in one consolidated place that people can then take with them on the road.
I honestly don't think our business would be as successful without the technology that we use.